i'll tell you another story about my
father so there there's this line that i
call
that i called the henry carlson line
um so at some point
you know he never knew a lot of openings
in in chess but i taught him
i taught him a couple of openings as
black
it's the
uh it's the specialty cup sicilian that
i've played a lot myself also um during
the um the world championship in 2018 i
won about a bunch of games in 2019 as
well so that's one opening and i also
taught him as black to play the ragosan
defense
um and then so the regulation defense
goes like goes like this
um it's characterized by
um by this bishop move
um and so uh he would play those
openings pretty
pretty exclusively and as black and the
tournaments that he did play and also
the svechnikov sicilian is like that's
the only
two of my sisters play i've played a
bunch of chess tournaments as well and
that's the only
opening they know as well so my my
family's reporter is very narrow so
so this is this this is the system black
goes here and then we are from white
takes the pawn and black takes the pawn
um
so at some point i was watching one of
my
my father's
online blitz game
this game and as white he played this
this
uh so this is called the car con defense
he took the pawn
um it was taken back then he went with
the knights
um his opponent went here and then he
played the bishop here
so i
i'd never seen this opening before and i
was like
wow
how on earth did he come up with that
and he said no i just played the ragosa
with the different colors because if the
knight was here it would be the same
position i was like i never
i was like how am i
like one of the
best players in the world i mean and
i've never thought about that so i
actually started playing
i started playing this line uh as white
with pretty decent results and in
results and it actually became
kind of popular and everybody
uh who asked about the line it's like i
would always tell them yeah that's the
henry carlson navigation
i wouldn't necessarily explain why it
was called that i would just always call
it that so i really hope at this point
at some point
this line will be uh will find its its
rightful name in uh yeah it finds its
way into the history books can you uh
what what what did you learn about life
from your dad what what role has your
dad play in your life
taught me a lot of things
but most of all
as long as you win a chess then
everything else is fine
[Laughter]
um i think
my
especially my father but my parents in
general they they always wanted me to
get a good education and um
find a job and so on um even though my
father loves chest and he wanted me to
to play chess i don't think
he had
any plans for me to be professional i
think things changed at some point like
i was less and less interested in school
and
for a long time we were kind of going
back and forth fighting about that um
especially my father but also my mother
a little bit
it was at times a little bit difficult
they wanted you to go to school yeah
they sort of wanted me to
do more school to have more options and
then
i i think at some point
they just gave up
but i think that sort of coincided when
i was actually starting to make real
money off tournaments and after that you
know everything's been
sort of easy and like in terms of the
family like
they've never
put any pressure on me or they've never
put any demands on me um they're just
yeah miners has to focus on chess that's
that that's um that's it like
i i think they taught me in general to
be
curious about the world and to get
a decent
general education not necessarily from
from school but like just knowing
um about the world around you and
knowing history and being you know just
being interested in society i think
in that sense they've done well
and he's been with you throughout your
chess career i mean there's something to
be said
about just
family support and love that you have
that you know
this world is a lonely place
it's good to have people around you
they're like yeah um they got your back
kinda you know yeah uh
it's a cliche but i think to some extent
all the people you surround yourself
with
they can help you a lot
it's only family that only has their own
interests at heart
and so
for that reason like my father is like
the only one that's been like constantly
in the team that and that he's always
been around and it's it's for that
reason that i know he has my back no
matter what
you